Hello, welcome to another edition of Corts Reports.
Mother's Day is right around the corner.
It's a great time to tell your mom how much you love her.
You could write her a special card like these.
Thank you mom for making me food so I don't die.
Dear Mom, thank you so much for being my mom.
If I had a different mom, I'd punch her in the face and go find you.
I think that would actually be good for the video.
The best person ever besides dad.
Love you, mom.
Now it's time for Corts on Sports.
The Nashville Predators are in round 2 of the Stanley Cup playoffs.
To get into the playoffs spirit, let's try our new Pekka Rinne goalie simulator.
I'm doing so bad.
I hate that.
That was the worst.
School's almost out so it's time to start planning summer vacations.
Let's use our simulator to visit some awesome vacation spots.
Hey, I'm in New York.
Let's go to a Broadway show.
Or maybe you prefer Hawaii?
Or say you want to go to Texas.
Howdy partner.
Or imagine being magically taken to Delaware.
Hi, I'm in Delaware.
For Corts Reports, I'm Carden Corts.
Happy Mother's Day, Mom.
I love you.